patience I mean it when I say patience
patience is not a thing telling young
people all the time to just be patient
that is the most ridiculous advice slow
and steady wins the race what's
interesting you and I disagree on the
use of the word patience like so
violently
what's that belief nation at seven I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be part of your daily
success routine patience or in patience
what's more important as an entrepreneur
we're gonna hear what ed Mallette Gary
Vee Tom bill you and myself think I hope
you enjoy I wanted to spell one thing
that I hear other influencers say out
there at social media on YouTube that
could not be more wrong which is telling
young people all the time to just be
patient you know enjoy your teens enjoy
your 20s you've got forever you're gonna
live to 130 there's no reason to get so
worried about being successful now and I
gotta tell you that is the most
ridiculous advice I don't care how many
followers the person has that's telling
you this they could not be more wrong
it's ridiculous and it's nonsense
there's no reason simply because of your
age that you should not be after that
you can't be hustlin is it 18 is it 28
is it 38 it's ridiculous because there
isn't a number if you've got the desire
to win if you want to be somebody if you
want to make your dreams come true I
don't care if you're 12 years old or 82
years old your age is irrelevant it's a
form of ageism to tell a young person
just be patient if you're like me my mom
and my dad didn't give me a business I
didn't start on second or third base
like some of these people that are
telling you somehow to be patient I had
to pick myself up by my bootstraps and
make something of my life and frankly
the sooner you get going the sooner you
start working on yourself
the sooner you make progress the sooner
you're gonna get there and enjoy your
life and so don't listen to that crowd
think about this when I was in my 20s I
made six figures early in my 20s by the
time I was thirty I was making seven
figures by the time I was 40 I was
earning an eight figure income what if
somebody who told me how cool it'd be
patient don't worry about it my entire
life would be different I wouldn't be
looking at the ocean live an oceanfront
now or flying on my jet or taking care
of my parents or having multiple homes
living on the lake
having multiple boats multiple cars
whatever the material things are
donating to the charities that I want
and I listen to that absurd ridiculous
stupid advice so please don't listen to
those people who tell you that they have
good intentions their time I'm not
putting pressure on yourself you've got
all kinds of time the truth is a little
pressure is probably pretty good for you
think about this Steve Jobs was in his
20s and teens when he started Bill Gates
Mark Cuban Kylie Jenner you taught any
entrepreneur that's out there today that
you know pretty well most of them
started young jay-z started young LeBron
James started young why is it that you
can't start young Steve Jobs did I did
cuban did Bill Gates did OH
there's thousands of unforce in fact the
the list of billionaires in the country
gets younger every single year as do the
millionaires you want to know why
because of these things right here
technology your phone your iPad social
media allows people at any age to win
including preteen and teenagers and so
please parents don't hold your kids back
if they want to grow the first 13 years
of my life weren't sexy
I was quiet and I built an actual
business
I was a 22 year old kid and I worked at
minute
[Music]
we're building businesses I used to work
in liquor store from 7:00 in the morning
to 10:00 at night for seven three years
and the only days off I took work to
watch the New York Jets you know I I
took over my family business it was
doing a couple million dollars a year
and over a seven-year period I built it
up to a 50 million dollar company turned
30 freaked out and decided I wanted to
do something else seventeen months I did
why why be TV five days a week I walked
away from being CEO of my company it was
just that drive that I just knew that I
had to do something different and I wish
all of you 13 16 19 and 24 year olds
could feel how young I am in my soul
right now it would change everything you
do you'd become dramatically more
patient which would mean that you would
make a lot more of the successes that
you want to happen most of you will lose
because you're trying to take shortcuts
slow and steady wins the race
you're only competing with yourself 25
just keep doing it for five years you'll
be a young man and he'll be there
patience I mean it when I say patient
when I was 25 years old I thought a
fully legless finished
I don't even feel like I'm stopped
I recommend it very seriously then you
go home and think about that that you
should probably allocate the next three
to four years of your life to try to
execute on the thing that you want to do
for the rest of your life just put in
work and enjoy that enjoy eating and
dirt and bleeding and the grind and
don't give about what anybody else
thinks why you haven't done it why are
you doing that have four jobs Wendy's
Walmart your side hustle work clean
learn you're 19 and you can spend seven
full years learning your craft meeting
people that are Mentors
being patient and you wake up and you're
26 years old
give your entire life in front of you
and you've done great foundational work
to go on and then you see
what I gave was my time when you know
how money you give your time
that was my patience that was my giving
back it's a balance of regret and
patience like you didn't go hard up a
three years do nothing right wake up and
be youngest I am convinced that people
do not understand that it takes patience
[Music]
my friends this is a remarkably special
time and I'm completely convinced the
far majority and I mean 99% of this room
is going to regret it I'm completely
convinced about it it's not fun for me
to say that but it's very obvious to me
that humans take [ __ ] for granted and
are really bad at perspective and timing
the reason I push patients how many
people here are under 30 raise your
hands
stand up if you're under 30 let's first
of all clap it up for all the youngsters
in the room keep standing
you're young you're not tired yet if
you're standing right now you really
have like let's get into perspectives
and actual understanding if you're
standing right now with the way that
modern medicine is actually evolving
there's a very high percentage that
you're gonna live three more lives that
you've already lived if not five like do
you understand why I struggle when
people give up on a year or two in or
are upset that they haven't gotten there
yet three years in when you phases are
about to live four more lives I'm being
serious
like you're literally gonna live four
more lives five more like from the day
you were born that you cannot remember -
right this second you're about to do
that three to four more times
you can sit literally literally your
biggest advantage is timing for all the
great things that I have in my life I
would literally give it up all of it all
of it just to be 25 I would give up for
17 years I'd give up everything I have
because that's how valuable time is and
the far majority of this room has time
time as their asset and every day the
number one asset they have time they
give away by being impatient mainly on
the back of listening to society or
their parents that they have to have
figured out at this age the fact that
people actually think at eighteen
twenty-two or thirty you have to have
your figured out is
Nicholas let me promise you all those
parents and uncles and grandparents that
push down your throat that you have to
figure it out by now they still haven't
figured at the I mean it
so this nonsense that you have to have
it figured out at eighteen twenty to
thirty you know many people freak the
[ __ ] out at thirty how many feeler
thirty right now that was crazy right
like people lose their at thirty like
meanwhile their kid and so I'm
unbelievably aware lately that one of
the you know people are just like why do
you when I talk about my parents and not
coming from anything but the more that I
live I'm like no reason I really win is
cuz I understand time and listen I know
I can get hit by a bus or get terminally
ill I get it
here's the problem that's far more
unlikely for the majority of us the math
works in your favor and we are
stunningly not patient patience has been
the foundation of my sick patients
adversity these are the foundations of
my success you absolutely do not hope
and wait oh god this is why I'm so anti
patients like it's not a thing it's not
a thing
patience is not a thing okay
now that doesn't mean that you don't
play the long game you need to play the
long game whatever it is that you want
but patience to me is a synonym to
relaxing - waiting - letting it happen -
thinking all things happen for a reason
which is all horse you've got to go
all-out every day to build your skill
set to make something happen that that
is truly the only way I'm about to give
you probably the most powerful
entrepreneurial advice greatness
achieving advice I am ever going to give
you you're going to ignore it as most
people do because it's very hard to get
your mind around that it's really this
simple but it's this simple
get rid of patience stop having the
patience to let things unfold naturally
now if you want to get ahead it's
going to take an obscene amount of time
I am NOT saying that my message is you
can make it happen overnight you
absolutely can't but let me tell you
right now even if you're giving yourself
10 years to become a DOP a director of
photography if you're gonna give
yourself 10 years to accomplish that I
promise you the only way it's gonna
happen is if you're saying to yourself
in every moment you're gonna bifurcate
your mind and I want people to
understand you will never win at the
highest level until you can hold two
competing ideas in your head and here
are the two ideas idea number one this
is gonna take me ten years idea number
two I'm gonna make it happen today and
I'm gonna ask myself every day why
didn't it happen today what thing did I
not do what skill set am I missing what
am I gonna have to do and I'm telling
you right now that has been the secret
to my success I was so desperate to make
things happen right now that I'm always
looking for what's the next massive leap
forward that it is not okay for me to
plan on it taking ten years because
secretly I know it's going to but it's
going to take ten years and only
actually going to happen for me if I'm
going all-out every day like it has to
happen right now you must hold the two
competing ideas in your head this is
gonna take a really long time and I
absolutely refuse for it to take a long
time and the reason that you do that it
gets you thinking totally differently if
your everyday you're thinking about 10%
incremental improvement she's never
gonna go anywhere if every day you're
forcing yourself to think I need to
10-fold this then all of a sudden you
think radically differently and in that
process through a lot of failure you'll
finally hit on something that actually
does let you go forward that fast that's
the secret
and if I could explain it really well I
like to think that it would be this
major breakthrough for people but I
don't explain this very well but it is
maybe not the most powerful thing any
human needs to learn but it's certainly
the most powerful thing any entrepreneur
needs to learn that's just what's
interesting you and I disagree on the
use of the word patience like so
violently these so my thing is patience
literally and but the thing is I always
tell people I know what Gary means and
Gary means play the longer patience
micro speed a thousand percent the
problem is when people hear patience
that getting a passiveness yes you use
the word passive though yeah exactly you
can't let people get into a passive that
situations patience
yeah but what I'm saying is when people
hear that word out of anyone's mouth I
understand they go in the wrong of
everybody semantically articulating the
manipulation of words to their non
meeting it's interesting so here's how I
love when like I love like like the
amount of judgment that is being thrown
on me right now in circles around people
manipulating the words that I'm like
it's absurd look patience is not passive
so my thing is how do people react to it
I couldn't agree more but the reality is
is if we are now in a place where we
can't allow the words to actually mean
what they mean we have to challenge that
conversation as well because now you're
getting into how people filter
everything and now we're talking about
the most important P which is
perspective if they're filter is taking
it then you're you that's what gets so
interesting about having to do this
one-on-one versus through content
content is vulnerable in its macro it's
super interesting very interesting and I
that on this particular thing like I'll
say forget the list because you and I
are saying the same thing so the last
thing I want to do is argue that when we
get to the point thousand percent and
I'm with you my thing is how do you get
people to realize that momentum is the
thing that I think matters so if you
have you ever been in like an
aboveground swimming pool and you can
start walking in a circle and it creates
the the vortex and then you could pick
your feet up and it's all fear thing I
was talking to you about that I got to
walk you through of like what you need
to do for your studio to like win the
world literally what internally for a
few minutes was called momentum
marketing nice you need to hustle while
you wait if you can embody this advice
and apply it to your business on a day
to day basis this will be the biggest
momentum shift in your company this
move you so close to your goals at an
incredible pace that is unbelievable
just most people don't do it
hustle while you wait listen with every
goal that you have it relies on other
people you need other people to be a
part of your process right if you're
selling to customers you need the
customer to say yes they have to make
the decision there's a bunch of back and
forth if you're waiting on a product to
come you're waiting on your supplier to
come forward this there's always things
that are outside your control that
you're waiting on other people for and
yes when it comes to you you want to get
it done as soon as possible
if a customer is asking for a quote you
want to get it off your plate ASAP you
should not be the bottleneck in momentum
happening in your business that's a
whole other problem as soon as something
comes to you it's getting taken care of
and you're building momentum but you're
still even at the most peak efficiency
waiting for other people to take action
that's gonna happen so what do you do in
those moments you hustle you build new
momentum you build new clients you build
new relationships you maintain the
existing ones and get everything done as
soon as possible and then in the
downtime while you're waiting for a
decision
you're not just twiddling your thumbs
you're not just sitting on the couch
you're not watching Netflix you're off
hustling new business quick example I
was doing a photo shoot with Richard
this guy's a celebrity photographer he's
done lady gaga done the whole bunch of
rappers he came over and we did a photo
shoot together and in between his shots
he's gonna set up lights he's got to get
his fog machine going he's got to get
the right angle he's got to set up the
green-screen
and so when he needs me I'm there I'm
ready I'm posing I'm in action I'm ready
to go but there's a lot of setup
in-between shots that's so what am i
doing I'm pulling up my phone and I'm
responding to you guys I'm making videos
I'm doing responses I'm getting on
Twitter and Instagram I'm doing on
snapchat I'm sending out Beauty
responses to you guys I'm working I'm
hustling on my downtime while I'm
looking for rich for this project I am
hustling connecting with you guys and
that's the approach that you need to
take people say well how do I find
to respond the people on social media I
probably have a way bigger cats than you
guys do and I find the time because I
make the time in between the other
things that I'm doing this is so
critical people are losing so much time
the answer is not to wake up two hours
early or think that's gonna solve your
problem the answer is you're losing time
every single day you are leaking
valuable time from your daily schedule
and so I highly highly highly encourage
you to take this message home while you
are working while people are waiting on
you for stuff you are doing your best to
deliver as soon as possible so that you
are not the bottleneck in your business
but then while you're avoiding other
people you get your hustle on you
continue to build momentum it is such a
hack to get you closer to achieving the
goals that you have for yourself stop
sleeping while you're waiting for the
people to get back to you hustle while
you wait so I've got two questions for
you
number one whose perspective did you
agree with the most and number two what
do you think about patients or
inpatients what's more important as an
entrepreneur limit on your thoughts in
the comments below if you want to know
how the world's most successful
entrepreneurs think check the link right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy
that video continue to believe and I'll
see you there in business a lot of
things or I call it folklore they're
done because they were done yesterday
and the day before